selina ist mit gerade einmal 16 jahren
verstorben
auf einer party nimmt sie laut
augenzeugen mehrere pillen ecstasy
trinkt dazu noch alkohol zu viel für den
jungen körper die 16 jährige bricht
zusammen ihre freunde rufen erst viel zu
spät den notarzt das junge mädchen
verstirbt noch auf der party bild trifft
kurz nach dem tragischen ereignis ihre
mutter yvonne der drogen tod ihrer
tochter für die 42-jährige unbegreiflich
hätte mir niemals im traum vorgestellt
dass meine tochter diese pillen wo nimmt
selina ist ein aufgewecktes junges
mädchen geht gerne feiern dass dabei
drogen im spiel sein könnte mahnt mutter
yvonne nie
am sonntagmorgen dann der schock dann
habe ich morgens um vier die nachricht
erhalten dass sie verstorben ist und im
nachhinein hat wurde wohl auch erzählt
dass sie alkohol konsumiert ecstasy war
mit dem spiel jetzt habe ich sogar
mitgekriegt dass der thc coca-cola guckt
selina soll möglicherweise die besonders
gefährliche panischer pille mit dem
totenkopf symbol genommen haben experten
warnen vor der unberechenbar hohen dosis
dieser ecstasy-tabletten mittlerweile
ist sogar klar wer celina die drogen
verkauft hat tim f die polizei stürmte
seine wohnung nimmt den gerade einmal 18
jährigen fest verdacht drogenhandel
bei seiner festnahme überraschen die
polizisten den drogendealer wir einem
anderen 18-jährigen gerade 76 gramm
marihuana verkaufen will
zudem werden zwei ecstasy pillen
sichergestellt tmf wird festgenommen
ist mittlerweile aber wieder auf freiem
fuß die ermittlungen laufen
christinas cousine ist die unterlassene
hilfeleistung von tmf und allen anderen
partygästen völlig unverständlich die
wollen lieber kein ärger bekommen wegen
drogen aber lassen ihre freundin sterben
ihre freunde ihre beste freundin lassen
sie stellen einen menschen der kommt
nicht mehr zurück aber die angst dass
die ärger bekommt von der polizei oder
von den eltern ein mensch gestorben
ein mensch was geht das getan ich ruft
doch den krankenwagen
auch für die leute die später wenn so
etwas passiert immer den krankenwagen
rufen
die familie hat nach dem tod ihres li na
nur einen wunsch dass die gefahr die von
drogen wie ecstasy ausgeht von eltern
und jugendlichen nie wieder unterschätzt
wird bei mir im studio ist jetzt die
mama von selina unglaublich tapfer dass
sie zu uns gekommen sind aus hamburg so
kurz nach dem tod von zilina haben sie
für sich eine erklärung gefunden wie es
überhaupt dazu gekommen konnte dass ihre
tochter diese pillen genommen hat in
dieser nacht vielleicht war das
mitgehangen mitgefangen sie wollte mit
läuft sie aber immer ein blick einzige
meine liebe mitläuferin glaube ich
wollte cool sein
sie ist nur ist das was sie ihren
kindern sehr mehrere kinder was wir alle
unseren kindern immer wieder sagen nehmt
keine drogen
sie werden das 1000 mal gemacht haben
machen sie sich vorwürfe heute dass sich
ihr so viel freiraum gelassen habe
vielleicht aber vertrauen war bei uns
immer sehr wichtig sie war mal ehrlich
zu mir
sie hat mir immer erzählt wenn irgendwas
war ja eigentlich vorwürfen
ja weil ich weil ich die freunde auch
nicht richtig kannte mit denen sie wohl
zuletzt zusammen war
also es war nicht ihr fester
freundeskreis es waren wohl viele neue
freunde mit dem kreis dabei ja die
freunde die ganz offenbar auch dann
diese pillen fertigt verkauft haben ganz
gezielt eben ein junger mädchen
jetzt will man die natürlich finden
diejenige und was wie läuft das im
moment machen sie sich hoffnungen da die
verantwortlichen wirklich zu stellen wir
wissen wer das war
das war jetzt nicht neuer freund das war
einer oder ihr bester freund wie die
sich sie hat ihn als bruder
eingespeichert am handy und
ja wir wissen da zu 99 prozent dass das
von ihnen kommt auch laut den was
passiert mit dem bis jetzt ich weiß
nichts also wir stehen da haben keine
akteneinsicht wir die polizei hat zuerst
totschlag mit todesfolge danach
ermittelt und jetzt hat die polizei mich
angerufen hat gesagt man hätte zulehner
nicht retten können sowieso nicht auch
bevor der krankenwagen also dass und das
glauben sie nicht nein nein das sie
glauben wenn man sofort geholfen hätten
davon den rettungswagen gerufen hätte
dann wäre sie linie möglicherweise noch
am leben und nach den ersten anzeichen
ich glaub ja weil kurz nach mitternacht
haben die schon miteinander
untereinander whatsapp geschrieben die
nicht auf da taten waren wie es
verlierer geht für dina geht schlecht
oder wollt ihr nicht über die mama
bescheid sagen habt ihr alle illegalen
sachen versteckt oder macht doch mal ein
foto von ihr damit ich sehe wie sie
aussieht und hätte man da vielleicht
schon den rtw gerufen dann hätte man
vielleicht auch was für zur diener
machen können das heißt offenbar ging es
denjenigen in denen moment mehr darum
nicht erwischt zu werden als um die
gesundheit ihrer tochter ich hatte vor
kurzem jetzt mit der gastgeberin ein
gespräch und die hat mir noch mal zu
gewiss ich habe sie gefragt warum sie
alle weg gelaufen sind sie haben gesagt
sie waren alle schockiert als sie zudem
auf dem boden gelegen sehen haben aber
vor wollten sie noch mit anderen
freunden den rtw rufen und derjenige der
die pillen fertigt hat oder verschenkt
hat hat einen noch gesagt ruft nicht den
rtw was geht ihnen durch den kopf wenn
sie jetzt ganz aktuell in hamburg hören
es gibt wieder neue dieser fälle ist wie
der junge mädchen eine 13 jährige die
jetzt in lebensgefahr im krankenhaus
liegt food wütend also man muss sich
zurückhalten auch als mama und derjenige
der ihr die pillen gegeben hat läuft
noch bei uns im ort herum und
fingen wir an finkenwerder genau und 500
meter fluglinie entfernt wohnt da von
uns wir können ihn tagtäglich sehen und
ich muss mich zusammenreißen wenn ich
ihn sehe
also was was können wir was können mamas
und papas tun die jetzt teenager haben
in hamburg oder in anderen großstädten
oder auch in kleineren städten was was
würden sie sagen offenbar reicht ja
nicht aus dass so viel polizei gibt all
diese leute diese netzwerke so schnell
zu durchschlagen was was können wir als
mamas und papas tun
das beispiel von joelina vorzeigen und
zwar gefällig
wir sind bild und wir liefern dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren